hello everyone and welcome to Game five
over the 2018 World Chess Championship
between Magnus Coulson and Fabiano
Caruana this is Game five all of the
previous four games have been drawn if
you haven't seen them I will put a link
to them in the description below you're
more than welcome to check it out as it
is a very intense Championship now in
this game Korona once again has the
white pieces and like in the previous
two rounds worker one I had the white
pieces
efore was played and then cross and
defended with a Sicilian that well at
some point became a Rosalie management
you know variation it will also be very
interesting what happens in this game
but before that I would like to share
with you a short poll I created on
Twitter it's it's lasted for only four
hours before I took the screenshot ask
the question that well not about the
prediction of the championship but about
who your pick is and is your choice good
for chess altogether like how it will
just benefit the most if Carson wins or
if Caruana wins so far 76% of you think
that it's Carson will win and that that
is good for chess but that is only from
732 votes and there was 20 hours left in
the poll so I will also shirt tomorrow
after Game six and we'll see if the
outcome changes also I would like to
share a couple of very nice photos are
also complimented by Nicki Riga there we
have attacker wanna arrives at the scene
Carson unlike Khurana yesterday did not
continue just sitting down but he tried
to get up obviously the handshake
happened too fast but it does look a bit
more appealing than the diagonal
handshake we faced yesterday also here
we have a very nice photo of a new
gentleman at the scene making the first
move for Fabiano also we can use it as a
photo challenge so who is the gentleman
making the first move for Fabiano i will
give it a you a little hint Europe using
his product almost every day you just
don't know it and for the third here we
have a nice photo of Carson Caruana the
first couple of moves are on the board
and
like I said as the photographers are
allowed to take photos they will usually
just play out the opening and then just
chill until everyone leaves so that
being said let's check out game five
Caruana has the white pieces and again
he opened with e4 once again Carlson
opens with c5 and I have something to
share with you about the entire
championship but hopefully I will
remember that for the end of this video
Sicilian game Cecil and defenses on the
board Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and here
we have Bishop to b5 again going into
the news Medina of attack or the Rosalie
more attack here it's basically the
Rosalie Martinez Medina has been using
it so much and he created such beautiful
games with it added and now it also
bears his name and you know I definitely
approve of the opening choice otherwise
how would I be able to say image Medina
so many times during a World Chess
Championship match we have g6 castles
Bishop to g7 and now comes rope to e1
here already in move five Caruana
goes into a different line he doesn't
capture the knight and six c6 like in
the previous games but rather first he
goes rook to e1 Crossen goes in five
nonetheless and now comes a move that
you're probably gonna think I'm teasing
you before but it is of the move that
was actually played in the game it is
not the first time this game was this
move has been played it's been played
plenty of times one of the one of the
more notable games is ATM back row
versus Alexander Greece rook where the
game continued with C capture some d4
and Grichuk was able to win the game
very nicely against back row seemingly
a3 leads to a to a kind of a wing gambit
type structure and then we should
continue with b3 I believe but in the
end he won a very nice game but it was a
rapid game from 2017 from the
Grantchester in Paris here after this
before
Carlson took some five minutes so it's
not like it comes as a super surprise
for him this b4 move I'm not still
taking five minutes at the first time in
the game where someone actually thinks
about the move
also I've seen some comments where
people said that Carlson was actually
just pretending and wasting and he
wasted time so perhaps Khurana would
think think that Carson his out of
preparation but I don't I don't think
you would actually waste time for
nothing in a world championship match
but then again who knows
Knight captures on before was played and
here we have Bishop to b2 played pretty
much instantly by Khurana also you know
we should consider or some Evans gambit
ideas possible here like c 3 and d 4 but
it doesn't doesn't appear to be so after
Knight to c6 and d4 let's say
pawn captures pawn captures pawn
captures here and now you can no longer
capture for example on c6 because after
D captures the Queen would also be
guarding in the d4 pawn so here after
Knight bTW - you don't want to allow
something like d3 to so this Bishop can
attack your look a 6 now Bishop captures
D captures and now after Bishop 283
preventing castle but not for long 97
and black will be fine like black will
be just better so such ideas are not
possible here c3 d4 so instead we have
Bishop to b2 like we said played
instantly and now again Carson takes a
couple of minutes here and he finds this
a6 move and again a lot of people were
considering ok but what what does Y to
do here if you just move the bishop
let's say Bishop e2 then black can even
go simply back Knight to c6
he keeps defending his d5 pawn he's just
up upon there's there's really no
compensation for White's wasted b2 b2
pawn would that be for move yes ok the
bishop is very nicely developed but if
you're not gonna get anything for the
pawn sacrifice now you're definitely not
gonna get anything for later but Khurana
here played a3 also a move he prepared
and now it's it's a bit of a different
different idea
here we have a captures on b5 again
Carson spends on 5 minutes on this move
and we have a capture Sun before so a
couple of exchanges here we have
captures captures and now comes d6 also
I'm aware
other moves can be can be played but
Carson actually played it fairly quickly
so seek we have be captures on c5 and
now comes nice to East seven if you play
D captures on c5 then you're a pawn
becomes a week a white can simply
capture it and after Bishop captures
Knight captures the material is now
equal both players have six pawns but
black has a slightly worse pawn
structure so white what would definitely
be better here so instead Carson goes
for Knights to e7 and now comes Queen to
e2 a very interesting move by Caruana
again he didn't spend all that much time
on it after pawn captures on d6 also
this could have been played Queen
captures on d6 and now before also
something karana said in the press
conference after the game he had
considered this line but then there's
nothing much here after a couple of
exchanges here captures captures
captures captures the b5 point is under
attack black can even push B for control
a3 control c3 the square this Knight can
use to enter the game and after
something like Knights to d2 black can
simply castle and the white will not be
able to use a DEA file and go make a
very nice rock cliff to be a rock a 8
because Ruby d8 will be a very nice move
for Black Knight comes to b3 and now
white also has to take care of some
future back ranked weaknesses so he will
definitely have to waste a move at some
point with the g3 or h3 but all in all
black will be perfectly fine here
so instead not capturing on d6 Khurana
was Queen e2 and now comes b4 basically
the only move that was good for black in
this position if you played anything
other than before if you if you tried
something like capturing or castling has
Queen captures on b5 is a threat by
playing this you and there's no real
good way to actually defend it you can
defend it with the bishop because then
the Queen is no longer defending the d6
pawn so you kind of have to do it before
what's played and now comes Queen to c4
and Queen b5 here doesn't really do all
that much if Queen b5 check you're not
gonna even pick up the pawn as nice the
c6 would guard
the pawn and now captures captures black
is black it's perfectly fine here d3
black will even castle and nothing to
worry about
so after b4 we have Queen to c4 about
Caruana and now comes Queen to a5 some 7
minutes were spent here and it's
actually a very nice move that forces
matters as the bishop is under attack on
e1 the bishop is unguarded and the
opponent before very conveniently
prevents the night on b2 sorry about
that for some reason it refuses to
become red the night and b1 cannot enter
the game and in the press conference
Khurana even said that he was actually
considering d4 here but you know he
thought that it was a ridiculous idea
but he said that he did consider it as
you know it was a lot of fun calculating
it and he was very much up on time so no
harm but it's actually not such a
ridiculous idea of course and actually
accepts which you know he doesn't have
to do it immediately then you can play
captures on d6 the knight has to move
after the knight moves you can play d5
after the knight moves again now you can
play Queen captures on b4 and here
whatever black does black can castle but
you would have a fairly dangerous pawn
structure here this pawn here this pawn
here
yeah the interface is giving me some
problems here and the double the D pawn
the blacks the black Bishop is currently
not doing all that much here and the
white would actually be better here
but the problem is with Coronas d4 that
calls and doesn't have to capture the
bishop immediately first he can get rid
of at least some of the points here D
captures on c5 you are threatening to
capture on d4 also the bishop is still
loose on a1 so now after d5 and queen
capture sunday 1 now it's a bit
different Queen captures on c5 now you
get to Bishop to g4 a nice developing
move and now white will be able to grab
a couple of points here for example
Queen b5 check pressure goes back
attacks Queen Queen captures on b7 and
now the King isn't allowed to castle
because white will simply write back the
piece but after Knight c8 Queen captures
on before again not allowing a black the
castle
it would be well black would still be up
his piece but I water where he could
castle safely and you know activate his
game it would be it was not all that
clear so definitely not something
ridiculous to think about I'm sure if
this was a blitz game after cross this
is a five Corona would most definitely
push d4 and we would have a very
creative game but it is the world chess
championship game and you know it's very
unlikely that we will see such moves see
capture Sundy sex was played by Khurana
now forcing the knight on e7 to move and
here we have Bishop to e6 first and in
between move attacking caranas Queen and
now we have Queen to c7 definitely the
strongest move now of course there's no
consideration of capturing an a1 because
you would be checkmated here Queen
captures on e7 is a threat of checkmate
so Carlsen trades Queens here we have
Queen captures pawn captures on c7 and
now Knight to c6 the b4 phone is now
defended the black King will be able to
enter the game and capture this pawn and
after the King moves from the back rank
even the rook will be able to enter the
game so c3 you do have to deal with this
b4 point somehow as the knight then I
still can't enter the game and there's a
it's hard to find a better way to do it
so c3 King to d7 across and uses this
precious time to get his King into the
game we have C capture some before
giving up this pawn but you know you
have other things to do
rook to e8 attacking the bishop on a1
and now as the bishop on a1 is under
attack and also the b4 ponies under
attack karana
spends actually 32 minutes considering
what to play here he plays Bishop the c3
which gets the bishop out of harm's way
and also protects the b4 pawn seems like
and seems like a really weird position
where we want to waste more than half an
hour as better up to c3 does seem to
solve all your problems
but there were things to consider like
you're gonna use this you're gonna lose
the c7 phone anytime now so maybe a move
like
want to see it promoting to a queen that
would push the black king back or even
make the route go back could be a
valuable tempo sometimes in the future
so also a thing to consider also I think
to consider would be perhaps b5 and now
after something like rook captures on a
1b captures in c6 with Czech pawn
captures and now Knight to c3 now
offering a rook trade the rook captures
Knight captures and now Bishop to h6
threatening Bishop to d2 with an attack
on both nights
so first Knight to f3 King captures on
c7 and only now Knight captures on e5
now it doesn't come with check but now
Bishop captures on d2 and black would
actually have a very nice position here
with the bishops pair and the past C
pawn so definitely a thing to consider
so like I said Bishop the c3 was played
but there were even ideas like Knight to
c3 maybe giving up the beef for pong
first
so after Knight capture some before you
can go a rook the b1 Knight moves now of
course you cannot capture on b7 with the
rook because the rook is still attacking
your Bishop on any one but after a move
like Knight to g5 which is also
something corona surely considered King
captures on c7 and Knight captures on e6
you double up black spots on D file and
now f3 again definitely a playable
position for white surely something
Khurana considered but he decided for
Bishop to c3 and it did take him some
like I said 32 minutes the two decide
upon it and this is only moon 19 so
still more than 20 moves to reach time
control we have King captures on c7 and
now d3 also a move corona spent some
time on as a lot of players were
actually considering Knight to g5 here
saying like it's a very nice smooth
threatening to capture and double wide
spawns here and also the threat of
capturing on h7 is there but then rook
to a 4 with a double attack on the b4
pawn and now ok you can capture on h7
then black is just gonna capture on
before nothing happens there but after
Knight captures on e6
with check pawn captures and here you
can play rook
- III a very nice idea that goes about
playing rook to f3 and rook to f7 and
now after Knight captures on b4 also you
might consider something like Bishop to
f8 to increase the pressure here which
does seem to be better because if
instead after rook to e3 you go Knight
capture some before immediately then
rope to f3 it comes with the threat of
rope to f7
so maybe first improving with Bishop to
f8 and only then White gets to decide
what to do but the b5 is actually very
nice here now after night the d4 blacks
position is excellent you're gonna get
to the b5 pawn any time now black our
White will have very difficult time
getting rid of this night from d4 if at
some point with the knight is captured
then black will fix this pawn structure
and also the rook is covering the a3
squared the bishop is stuck on c3 and
the pawn on D to the night still has no
way of actually entering the game so
while a lot of people were suggesting
Knight to g5 Khurana seems finds that it
is best to play d3 and find a way for
this night to enter the game and here
a lot of people again said that b5 is
the strongest idea for Carlsen some of
the things that the official
commentators from any website don't
enjoyed it is that everyone just walks
around with a smartphone when I was in
London for the first of game 1 and 2 it
was you know there were people who were
just enjoying the games were watching
the moves you know enjoying the magic
but a lot of people were actually
watching says during Norwegian
supercomputers evaluation at all times
so it kind of kind of spoiled the fun
but ok here a lot of people were saying
b5 is the absolute best as it fixes the
pawn on b4 and after deponent before is
fixed only then will you be able to
attack a true k4 Bishop to f8 go after
this weakness but Carson actually spends
22 minutes and he decides for King to b6
and well I haven't found anything wrong
with the bishop to pawn to b5 but surely
cousin figured that there that there was
point in going after this because now
after something like look to see one
trying to create some attacks as the
king also occupies the C file King b7
and now Bishop to d2 would be would be a
very nice move if looked to a for going
after the B for pawn now white can go
Knight g5 and after a try of not
allowing the whites to capture the pawn
now pawn Knight captures we have pawn
captures and it seems like a like a very
playable position for black the bishop
will still be able to attack the b4 pawn
via Bishop to f8 at some point black
will win the point so it's it's very
interesting to see why why Carson
decided it was best and not to play it
but okay
Carson decided after d3 to go King to b6
and here very very very likely comes a
move that most likely cost and missed if
there wasn't this move Quora wanna play
the perhaps kink the b6 was in fact the
better moved and then pawn to b5 here
Bishop to d2 was played now offering the
beaver pond and preparing b5 but also
with this Bishop to d2 move Bishop to e3
is coming and also the bishop frees the
c3 square for the knight and here again
cousin spends some 11 minutes for rook
to d8 but it's very interesting if you
play Bishop to f8 to prepare an attack
against the before pawn then white can
actually push b5 like we've mentioned
and after King captures now you can
Knight the c3 check King back to b6 and
now Knight to d5 check taking away the
c7 square or from black Kings blacks
King Bishop captures pawn captures and
now tonight's the B for Luke to be one
attacking the knight it seems that
there's a very little you can do to
protect the night you can go rook play
four but even better is king to c7
because now after white captures the
knight and black recaptures there's no
way for you to actually capture the
bishop because of rook to a-1 and after
we give up the rook and the knight black
will check mated the White King so
instead after this Bishop capture some
before you will have to play Knight
captures on e5 and
then comes f5 simply not allowing white
the capture it rope the c1 and now you
can even play King to d6 attack the
knight Knight to c4 check King moves and
now after g3 as you have to create some
breathing room for the White King to
avoid further back ranked weaknesses b5
Knight moves and now Ruby 8 putting a
rug behind the passed pawn and now after
the bishop moves black will also start
pushing his past pawn and will have a
very nice game all in all an equal ish
game so after Bishop to d2 the move cost
and perhaps missed rook to d8 here after
11 minutes as we mentioned and here
Bishop to e3 check also a way to defend
the d3 porn was a rook to d1 now of
course you cannot capture because of
Bishop to e3 opens up a discovered
attack here you would have to give it up
but still after night after Sun before
you know doesn't seem like white would
have that much of an easy task
converting this which would block the
bishop pair but still no point in you
know risking anything so Bishop to e3
check King moves to b5 and Knights the
c3 check we have King captures on before
and now comes Knights the d5 chip Bishop
captures pawn captures and now comes
Luke captures on d5 so here Carson is
again up a pawn but only only briefly
rook to be 1 check King to c3 and now
rook captures on b7 it was a crucial to
get rid of this b7 pawn and here Knights
to d8 you might think that efore is a
really powerful move here as of course
you cannot capture a due to roof to d1
this would result in checkmate but one
thing that a white can do is actually
simply ignore you and capture on f7 and
now after you capture on f3 rook
captures on g7 King chapter son d3 and
now pawn captures now on f3 as well 95
now rook captures on h7 Knight captures
on f3 with check King g2 kingi for
rookie 7 check rookie 5 blocks
captures on e5 and after night captures
on e5 you would have this position where
white is actually up upon unlikely that
this this would be winning but still you
don't want to allow this so at night to
the attacking the rook and also
defending the f7 phone we have looked to
c7 check you do have to move the rook so
why not to do it which tempo the King
has to move now you can't approach any
further because the bishop is guarding d
4 and D 2 so simply king chapters on D 3
again Carson is up upon but it will be
very hard to do to do anything with this
extra pawn King to f1 Fabiana wants to
bring his king into the game we have h5
now the DF DF 1 and the bishop will be
able to move as the h7 pawn will no
longer be a target
we have h3 and now comes King to e4
trying to go deeper into the position
Knight to g5 check and now even kink to
f5 we have knife captures on f7 Knight
captures on f7 rook captures on f7 and
Bishop to f6 and here karana simply
played g4 this comes with check and it
was in this position and move 34 that
the players agreed to a draw
why did they agree to a draw well after
H captures H captures King will simply
attack the roof and after the rook moves
now you get rook to be six and it's an
equal position both players have a rook
a bishop and two pawns nothing much to
be done here so you know all in all a
fair game and and a very fighting draw
once again for the third game Cora wanna
play d4 Carlsen defended with the
Sicilian we had the Rosalie mode Dinesh
Medina Rosalie MOU attack and once again
Corwin and managed to surprise Carlsen a
little bit but then again coral cross
and got to the upper hand after after
being surprised so it's it's seems very
nice that Corona about plays crossing in
the opening cross and spends a whole lot
of time but then you know come comes
back on top and it's very interesting
the quote above the board cousin says my
favorite
from the past is myself from some three
to four years ago if you've happened to
catch the press conference after the
game they asked both Carson in Khurana
who was their favorite player from the
past Khurana says that in terms of you
know how much one or how much how
excellent chess he played I definitely
Bobby Fischer but cross and said that it
was actually himself some three to four
years ago so there we have it and like I
said I wanted to mention something about
the entire match as this is the fifth
game that was already drawn that's
nothing out of the ordinary of the
ordinary a lot of games will be drawn in
the World Chess Championship match
because the stakes are simply too high
and there's simply no you know room to
play an interesting line to play
something that is not absolutely proven
by or you know engine proof everyone has
to come you know prepared with engine
lines but you know don't look on this
entire water championship event as you
know in by looking at the games you have
to look at look at the entire event as a
whole and you know they'll consider this
like the players simply trying to find
cracks you know in each other's armor
who knows maybe maybe tomorrow in Game
six across and we'll you know have
enough maybe he will play E for maybe we
will see a Petrov for the first time as
that's pretty much what everyone's been
talking about for the past year will we
see a Petrov between cross and Caruana
and also interesting s cross and did
pick the black pieces for game number
one now he finishes at the first half of
the match which the white pieces and
also he will start the second half of
the match with the white pieces
so now Crossen has white pieces at two
games in a row and here it will be very
interesting if he doesn't do anything
here then he is of course left with two
blacks to whites and and three blacks
and it will be Khurana to do something
so now it's very interesting and I still
think the match even though we're only
getting only we've only arrived up to
game six that it's uh like a like a
ticking bomb and I'm very interested if
you agree with
this because everyone else Carson is the
best player in the world when it comes
to to quicker time controls he will not
always win against everyone but if you
fit if you confront him with everyone
and everyone has to play like a lot of
games against him I believe he will
prevail against everyone
so Caruana most likely knows this that
if he continues drawing every game
drawing every game running every game
after 12 12 games of classical time
format we will have four rapid games and
then we go into blitz so I'm sure
Khurana also knows unless he was
secretly practicing how to play faster
time controls this entire time that
Carlson with every draw it's actually
causing who is closer and closer to
keeping his title as a world champion
and also I don't know if you had a
chance to catch an interview with Hikaru
Nakamura where he mentioned that it
would be very weird if Caruana wins this
world championship match because then we
would have a a world champion who is a
who who is bad at faster time controls
which is not something you would expect
expect out of the world champion
so I'm also very interested in what do
you think about Nakamura's saying in his
interview and yeah that's basically it
for game 5
you know I you should consider this
entire event like like the movie matrix
like if you just you know investigate
part 1 2 & 3 individually then you will
say ok and part 1 is excellent and then
2 & 3 are just like you know but if you
consider the trilogy as a Holden okay
it's a very nice story it's a very nice
idea I mean why not and that's how you
should basically you know consider the
World Chess Championship event
whadya I do hope you enjoyed this game
and hopefully I mean tomorrow we will
see a very nice game maybe even a petrov
like we mentioned i would like to thank
danny McCullough in our new room acutal
Krishnan Nicola Bullock Edward Fagin and
Joseph of Einstein for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos he are thankful
for watching and I will see you soon
maybe with a
in between game before game six but if
not definitely with Game six of the 2018
World Chess Championship match thank you
all and I will see you soon